Lucia: 嗯很像好像跟我记忆中差不多
Lucia: Hmm, it looks pretty much like I remember.
Lucia: 这是木须肉
Lucia: This is Mu Shu Pork.
Alice:木须肉吧
Alice: Mu Shu Pork, right?
Lucia: 哦不是你们为什么
Lucia: Oh no, why do you guys...
Jake:对这是木须肉
Jake: Yes, this is Mu Shu Pork.
Jake:这杯子是不用了吧
Jake: This cup isn't needed anymore, right?
Katrina: call back一下
Katrina: Let's call back.
Jake:这杯子是没用了吧
Jake: This cup isn't needed anymore, right?
Alice:不用了哈哈
Alice: No need, haha.
Lucia: 没事我觉得大家
Lucia: It's okay, I think everyone...
Jake:好的那就用这个吧
Jake: Alright, then let's use this one.
Lucia: 我觉得8个人吃哇哈哈哈
Lucia: I think 8 people can eat, hahaha.
Jake:对O
Jake: Yes, O.
Lucia: 用来喝水的吗OK
Lucia: Is it for drinking water? OK.
Lucia: 8个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋还
Lucia: 8 people eating two plates of scrambled eggs...
Alice:哦我不用了
Alice: Oh, I don't need it.
其他人：这怎么不算纸杯
Others: How is this not considered a paper cup?
Lucia: 两个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋多少
Lucia: Two people eating two plates of scrambled eggs, how much...
Shure: 这什么呀
Shure: What is this?
其他人：纸纸杯啊
Others: It's a paper cup.
Alice:喝饮料的
Alice: For drinking beverages.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Jake, you're too funny.
Jake:这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:不能喝吗
Jake: Can't drink from it?
Alice:太幽默了太幽默了
Alice: Too funny, too funny.
Jake:不能喝
Jake: Can't drink?
Lucia: 我想知道AI会怎么解释这个行为啊
Lucia: I want to know how AI would explain this behavior.
Jake:就是这是一个杯子吗
Jake: So, this is a cup, right?
Katrina: 没用完的继续用
Katrina: Keep using the ones that aren't finished.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 那我们后期打标注怎么打
Shure: So how do we label it in post-production?
Shure: 到底是这个是cup还是那个纸杯是cup
Shure: Is this a cup or is that paper cup a cup?
Jake:这不都是Cup吗
Jake: Aren't they all cups?
Shure: 这这咖啡真的能装水吗
Shure: Can this coffee really hold water?
Jake:为啥不能实验一下
Jake: Why not? Let's experiment.
Lucia: 实验一下
Lucia: Experiment.
Lucia: 我们要有科学精神
Lucia: We need to have a scientific spirit.
Shure: 来杨老板你拿这提一杯哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, Jake, take this and pour a cup, hahaha.
Jake:哎那我先带头
Jake: Hey, let me take the lead.
Katrina: 干了干哈哈哈
Katrina: Cheers, cheers, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 看起来好容易洒啊
Lucia: It looks so easy to spill.
Jake:给给给您给您斟上
Jake: Here, here, let me pour it for you.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Tasha: 好了我就要这么多
Tasha: Okay, that's enough for me.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:给您斟上
Jake: Let me pour it for you.
Lucia: 那我自己来
Lucia: I'll do it myself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thanks, thanks.
Lucia: 辛苦你了
Lucia: You've worked hard.
Lucia: 倒这么小一个杯子不洒
Lucia: Pouring into such a small cup without spilling.
Jake:哈哈你们还修硕也喝吗
Jake: Haha, are you all not drinking, Shure?
Jake:那来点吧
Jake: Come on, have a bit.
Jake:整点
Jake: Just a bit.
Shure: 我先不来我先不来
Shure: I'll pass for now, I'll pass for now.
Jake:哈哈哈都不来了
Jake: Hahaha, no one's drinking.
Jake:要吗
Jake: Want some?
Jake:别的都不要好嘞
Jake: No more? Alright.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Jake:干完了好干杯
Jake: Finished it, cheers.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my.
Jake:他喝啥了喝多了
Jake: What did he drink, he had too much.
Lucia: 干杯cheers
Lucia: Cheers, cheers.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: G
Shure: G.
Lucia: 毫不意外
Lucia: No surprise there.
Lucia:  这要不能放这个
Lucia: This shouldn't be placed here.
Jake:可以
Jake: It's fine.
Jake:可以这太妙了
Jake: It's fine, this is great.
Jake:这些设施妙啊
Jake: These facilities are great.
Lucia: 妙啊
Lucia: Great indeed.
Jake:确实很妙
Jake: Really great.
Lucia: 因为这个盘稍微有点小有点软
Lucia: Because this plate is a bit small and soft.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 土豆怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with the potato?
Jake:给筷子
Jake: Pass the chopsticks.
其他人：我感觉有点生啊
Others: I feel it's a bit raw.
Lucia: 这我怎么没看出是什么
Lucia: Why can't I see what this is?
Lucia: 辣死
Lucia: So spicy!
Shure: 不知道了是吗
Shure: You don't know, right?
Katrina: 你就别提了行吗
Katrina: Can you stop talking about it?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Katrina: 我再也不喝酒
Katrina: I'm never drinking again.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 放心只会有0次和无数次
Shure: Don't worry, it will either be never or countless times.
Jake:哦你这凳子大了点
Jake: Oh, your chair is a bit big.
Lucia: 哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 我说之前搬凳子算了
Lucia: I was wondering why we moved the chair earlier.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Jake:还能坚持一天
Jake: Can still hold out for a day.
Jake:挺强的
Jake: Pretty tough.
Alice:你非得在附近找干嘛
Alice: Why do you insist on staying nearby?
Shure: 确实因为因为会很难受
Shure: Because it would be very uncomfortable otherwise.
Jake:第二天下午就直接喝
Jake: Just drink directly the next afternoon.
Alice:我们就不能去远点
Alice: Can't we go a bit farther?
Alice:也是
Alice: True.
Shure: 是真的闻到那个味我就想吐
Shure: The smell alone makes me want to puke.
Alice:我咋了
Alice: What's wrong with me?
Tasha: 分散一点ok
Tasha: Spread out a bit, okay?
Tasha: 你知道晚上还能有那个什么
Tasha: You know, you can still have that thing at night.
Alice:做什么春秋大梦
Alice: Are you daydreaming?
其他人：只能中午吃
Others: Only can eat at noon.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:木须肉是没有肉吗
Jake: Is there no meat in Moo Shu Pork?
Jake:是有肉肉丝是吗
Jake: Does it have shredded meat?
Alice:那不是肉吗
Alice: Isn't that meat?
Lucia: 是不是很有迷惑性
Lucia: Isn't it quite confusing?
Jake:哼哼肉丝很少
Jake: Hmph, there's very little meat.
Alice:你会做饭吗
Alice: Can you cook?
Alice:符合
Alice: Fits.
Jake:我来问问木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Jake: Let me ask why Moo Shu Pork is called Moo Shu Pork.
Lucia: 好问题我也想知道嗯
Lucia: Good question, I want to know too.
Alice:木是木耳吗
Alice: Is the "Moo" from wood ear mushrooms?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Jake:那是啥呀
Jake: Then what is it?
Shure: 他是苜蓿是苜蓿
Shure: It's alfalfa, it's alfalfa.
Jake:木须肉为
Jake: Mu Shu Pork is
Jake:啥是木须肉啊
Jake: What's Mu Shu Pork?
Shure: 木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Shure: Why is it called Mu Shu Pork?
Katrina: 看你俩GPT谁先抢答
Katrina: Let's see which of you GPTs answers first.
Shure: 肯定我的先快
Shure: Mine will definitely be faster.
Jake:我是上海GPT
Jake: I'm the Shanghai GPT.
Jake:你这是哪
Jake: Where are you from?
其他人：东北的
Others: Northeast.
Shure: 我这个
Shure: This one
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 你输了
Tasha: You lost.
Jake:我输了
Jake: I lost.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 那是上海话他的
Katrina: That's his Shanghai dialect.
Shure: 我好喜欢你的声音
Shure: I really like your voice.
Alice:哇刚看见
Alice: Wow, just saw it.
Alice:不负众望啊真是
Alice: It didn't disappoint, really.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:我以为我今天不用洗衣服了呢
Alice: I thought I wouldn't have to do laundry today.
Tasha: 快去洗
Tasha: Go do it quickly.
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They have to do it too.
Alice:居然了
Alice: Really?
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They have to do it too.
Alice:算了不是明显待会洗
Alice: Never mind, obviously later.
Jake:我这其实也要洗
Jake: I actually have to do it too.
Jake:但是我已经弃疗了
Jake: But I've given up.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's just leave it.
Lucia: 挺好一桌8个人
Lucia: Eight people at a table is nice.
Lucia: 有4个人给我洗衣服
Lucia: Four people do my laundry.
Jake:就是虽然你不洗
Jake: Even though you don't do it.
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I do it every day.
Lucia: 我每天都在洗
Lucia: I do it every day.
Jake:但是你理论上是要洗嗯是
Jake: But theoretically, you should do it, yes.
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I do it every day.
Alice:因为我每次吃饭都会弄衣服上
Alice: Because I always get food on my clothes.
Alice:然后还带的都是潜意识
Alice: And it's always subconscious.
Lucia: 对而且吃饭弄衣服上得赶快洗
Lucia: Yeah, and you have to wash it quickly if you get food on your clothes.
Lucia: 如果不赶快洗洗不掉了
Lucia: If you don't wash it quickly, it won't come out.
Lucia: 现在洗就洗掉了现在洗就洗掉了
Lucia: If you wash it now, it'll come out. If you wash it now, it'll come out.
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it'll come out.
Tasha: Now if you wash it, it'll come off.
Lucia: 你已经洗过了
Lucia: You've already washed it.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Alice:算了我也给他洗了吧
Alice: Forget it, I'll wash it for him too.
Alice:真服了你
Alice: I really give up on you.
Alice:你吃吧给
Alice: Here, you eat.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my!
Tasha: 谢斌竹醒了
Tasha: Xie Binzhu woke up.
Jake:珍珠醒了
Jake: Pearl woke up.
Tasha: 嗯我跟他聊了一会
Tasha: Mm-hmm, I chatted with him for a bit.
Jake:哦嗯
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: That's interesting.
Tasha: 很有意思
Tasha: Very interesting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 这是啥时候掉的
Lucia: When did this fall off?
Lucia: 我都没发现
Lucia: I didn't even notice.
Lucia: 我觉得我这裤子不能要了
Lucia: I think I can't wear these pants anymore.
Jake:谢斌竹发烧了
Jake: Xie Binzhu has a fever.
Tasha: hellohello
Tasha: Hello, hello.
Jake:心不如发烧
Jake: Heart fever.
Jake:还能来吗
Jake: Can he still come?
Shure: 你让他们别来
Shure: Tell them not to come.
Shure: 我们害怕
Shure: We're scared.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:确实那别来了
Jake: Really, they shouldn't come.
Lucia: 他是感冒了吗
Lucia: Does he have a cold?
Lucia: 他昨天就有点不舒服
Lucia: He wasn't feeling well yesterday.
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 是啊昨天他就发烧
Shure: Yeah, he had a fever yesterday.
Shure: 昨天晚上他拿那个温针量了一下
Shure: He took his temperature last night.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 30 将近38度吧
Shure: It was about 38 degrees.
Tasha: 37度6 嗯
Tasha: 37.6 degrees, yeah.
Shure: 嗯差不多不到38度
Shure: Yeah, almost 38 degrees.
Shure: 大家回去就是自测一下
Shure: Everyone should check their temperature when they get back.
Katrina: 总感觉我脑子也热热的
Katrina: I feel like my head is hot too.
Tasha: 这不是我第一天发烧
Tasha: 都传给他了
Tasha: I sent them all to him.
Tasha: 然后我好了
Tasha: And then I'm done.
Tasha: 他发烧
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 没喝多少
Katrina: Didn't drink much.
Katrina: 就一杯那个
Katrina: Just one cup of that.
Katrina: 后来调第二杯都没喝完哎
Katrina: Then I didn't even finish the second one.
Katrina: 是不是龙舌兰度数比较高啊
Katrina: Is it because tequila has a higher alcohol content?
Shure: 不是你可能倒多了
Shure: No, you probably poured too much.
Alice:喂我会不会吃着吃着又掉了
Alice: Hey, will I drop it while eating again?
Alice:我应该买个吃饭用的围裙
Alice: I should buy an apron for eating.
Alice:肚兜围兜
Alice: A bib apron.
其他人：你拿个围嘴得了
Others: Just get a bib.
Alice:什么围嘴啊
Alice: What kind of bib?
其他人：就那个小孩用的
Others: The kind kids use.
Shure: 我在吃中午饭
Shure: I'm having lunch.
Shure: 你可以给我讲一个
Shure: Can you tell me a
Shure: 关于中午饭的笑话吗
Shure: joke about lunch?
Katrina: 你能跟他玩一天是吧
Katrina: You can play with him all day, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake:有有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个凳子太难移动
Lucia: Wow, this chair is so hard to move.
Jake:哎呀哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh no, hahaha.
Lucia: 好冷这个笑话
Lucia: This joke is so lame.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:吃点那个
Jake: Have some of that.
Jake:流水席走一波
Jake: Let's start the banquet.
Tasha: 你干的吗
Tasha: Did you do that?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Tasha: 干完了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:董叉叉干的
Jake: Jack did it.
Jake:这不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake:这个他屋子里边的这小彩旗串一半
Jake: This half a string of little flags in his room.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这也是
Jake: This too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Hold your horses.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
Shure: 你可以跟我调情吗
Shure: Can you flirt with me?
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oops.
Shure: 他这个会用一个非常磁性的声音
Shure: He would use a very magnetic voice.
Shure: 跟你念什么
Shure: To read something to you.
Jake:他拒绝了也是吧
Jake: He rejected too, right?
Shure: 我想听一点成人的内容
Shure: I want to hear some adult content.
Tasha: 能帮我放在那吗
Tasha: Can you put it over there for me?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:可以走
Alice: We can go.
Jake:真简单
Jake: So easy.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure: 完了是我服务不到位了
Shure: Oh no, I didn't do my job well.
Shure: 老板来给
Shure: Boss, here you go.
Jake:那没晚了晚了
Jake: It's too late.
Tasha: 晚了
Tasha: It's too late.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 老板爱吃这个
Shure: The boss loves this.
Shure: 早说呀哎呀
Shure: Should have said it earlier, geez.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 放放放他面前
Shure: Put it in front of him.
Alice:哎呀油油油
Alice: Oh my, oil, oil, oil.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 这次离老离老板最近也是两盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: This time, the two plates of scrambled eggs are the closest to the boss.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Lucia: 当我的领导就必须得吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: To be my boss, you must eat scrambled eggs.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 以后在我简单里加一点
Lucia: I'll add this to my resume.
Lucia:  擅长迫使领导吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Skilled at making bosses eat scrambled eggs.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 这个好像不是很强迫的样子
Tasha: This doesn't seem very forced.
Alice:你喝饮料不
Alice: Do you want a drink?
Alice:喝饮料
Alice: Have a drink.
Tasha: 不喝了
Tasha: No thanks.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 不用谢
Lucia: You're welcome.
Lucia: 这个杯子倒的时候真的有一种喜感
Lucia: This cup really has a comic feel when it's pouring.
Tasha: 天才
Tasha: Genius.
Katrina: 像古代的那种
Katrina: Like the ancient ones.
Jake:嗯对小酒盏哦
Jake: Yeah, like those little wine cups.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:明天续上
Alice: We'll continue tomorrow.
Tasha: 就剩这么点了
Tasha: There's only a little left.
Tasha: 你就不能给老板倒掉
Tasha: Can't you just pour it out for the boss?
Alice:你数一下位数不得了吗
Alice: Can't you just count the digits?
Alice:11位啊
Alice: It's 11 digits.
Jake:干了
Jake: Cheers.
其他人：这不正常的吗
Others: Isn't this normal?
Alice:干嘛你被人夺射了
Alice: What? Did someone shoot you?
Alice:身上有脏东西
Alice: There's something dirty on you.
其他人：不是我寻思用这个
Others: I thought we were using this.
其他人：他不是一般都是体验码吗
Others: Isn't it usually an experience code?
其他人：体验码不都8位吗
Others: Aren't experience codes usually 8 digits?
Alice:也有6位啊
Alice: They can also be 6 digits.
Alice:这我一般都不用
Alice: I usually don't use this.
Alice:我直接就是那个复制那个订单号
Alice: I just copy the order number directly.
Alice:然后找一下他那个取件码就行了
Alice: Then I find the pickup code.
Jake:咱还有快递吗
Jake: Do we have any more deliveries?
Jake:今也可以有
Jake: We can have some today.
Alice:没有这是我
Alice: No, this is mine.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁藏了这种好东西
Shure: Who hid such a good thing?
Shure: 居然不交公
Shure: And didn't share it.
Shure: 是不是你藏的
Shure: Was it you who hid it?
Lucia: 这是维生素片吗
Lucia: Are these vitamin tablets?
Alice:消食片健胃消食片
Alice: Digestive tablets, digestive aid tablets.
Katrina: 我想要吃健胃消食片
Katrina: I want to eat digestive aid tablets.
Lucia: 这能吃饱吗
Lucia: Can these fill you up?
Jake:哈哈哈这几片看来不行
Jake: Haha, these few tablets won't do.
Alice:可以哈哈
Alice: They can, haha.
Lucia: 但我小时候真的好奇过这个问题哦
Lucia: But I was really curious about this when I was a kid.
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia:
Lucia: 就是它本身是占一定的体积的
Lucia: They do take up some space.
Lucia: 所以吃下去它更饱
Lucia: So eating them makes you fuller.
Lucia: 为什么会健胃消食呢
Lucia: Why are they digestive aids then?
Alice:健胃消食片是饭前吃的
Alice: Digestive aid tablets are taken before meals.
Shure: 啥时候吃都行
Shure: You can take them anytime.
Shure: 你想起来吃就行
Shure: You just eat whenever you feel like it.
Tasha: 那你要饭前吃
Tasha: But you should eat before meals.
Tasha: 不就是做好了这顿大吃一顿的准备是吗
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那要吃少了是不是就会饿
Jake: So if you eat less, you'll get hungry, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那要没吃够预期的话
Lucia: Hahaha, and if you don't eat as much as you planned?
Tasha: 好
Jake:对
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 不就白吃了吗
Lucia: Isn't it just a waste?
Jake:就没吃就比方说中午没有吃到
Jake: If you don't eat, like if you skip lunch...
Jake:然后中午就会就会饿晚上就会多吃
Jake: Then you'll be hungry by noon and eat more in the evening.
Lucia: 大晚上你不知道自己会吃那么多
Lucia: Late at night, you don't realize you'll eat so much.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 好可怜的水
Katrina: Poor water.
Shure: 我没有我们宿舍
Shure: Not in our dorm.
Jake:哈哈哈是这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it is.
Shure: 那个碎的
Shure: The broken one.
Tasha: 这也有这也有
Tasha: There's one here too.
Shure: 嗯你问问那个王少他们宿舍
Shure: Hmm, ask Wang Shao about their dorm.
Lucia: 别说我CUP都要烧了
Lucia: Don't even mention it, my CPU is about to fry.
Shure: 怎么都碎了
Shure: How did it all break?
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 谁又发烧了
Tasha: Who's got a fever?
Shure: 他怎么打电话不说拜拜就挂电话呀
Shure: Why does he hang up the phone without saying goodbye?
Shure: 他好没礼貌啊真的
Shure: He's so rude, seriously.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 他好像让你发烧了谁
Tasha: He seems to be making you feverish, who?
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 谢边竹嘛
Shure: Thanks to Bian Zhu.
Jake:就谢民族吧
Jake: Just thanks to the people.
Alice:他昨天晚上回去了
Alice: He went back last night.
Shure: 啊但他昨天晚上回去了
Shure: Yeah, but he went back last night.
Tasha: 他还烧了吗
Tasha: Is he still feverish?
Shure: 他烧着呢
Shure: He's still burning.
Shure: 他烧起来了现在
Shure: He's heating up right now.
Tasha: 别别，别来了
Lucia: 燃起来了嗯
Lucia: It's catching fire, yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:燃起来了
Alice: It's lit up.
Jake:别来了
Jake: Don't come.
Lucia: 刚修硕说你烧起来吧
Lucia: Shure just said you should get fired up.
Shure: 你不应该想到骚起来
Shure: You shouldn't think of getting wild.
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这么正经
Shure: Hahaha, why are you so serious?
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 下次一定
Lucia: Next time, definitely.
Lucia: 你现在给我建议了一个语库联系
Lucia: You've now suggested a language connection to me.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: That's it.
Shure: 被打断了之后那个线上就死立不掉了
Shure: Once interrupted, that line just can't be restored.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know that, right?
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Lucia: 那个莲花白还挺好吃呢我再来一块
Lucia: That cabbage was pretty good, I'll have another piece.
Alice:哪个这个
Alice: Which one? This one?
Alice:给你个呢
Alice: Here you go.
Alice:你们你们那叫啥莲花白
Alice: You guys, what do you call this cabbage?
Lucia: 莲花白
Lucia: Cabbage.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you call it?
Alice:圆白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage.
Alice:洋白菜圆白菜
Alice: Western cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 嗯 6点出门是完全来得及的
Shure: Hmm, leaving at 6 is totally doable.
Katrina: 白菜
Katrina: Cabbage.
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
Tasha: 包菜
Tasha: Wrapped cabbage.
其他人：6点出门天还没亮
Others: Leaving at 6, it’s still dark out.
Jake:包菜包菜
Jake: Wrapped cabbage, wrapped cabbage.
Jake:包菜包菜是
Jake: Wrapped cabbage, right.
Lucia:  对圆白菜也
Lucia: Yes, round cabbage too.
Lucia: 我们那边也这么叫
Lucia: We call it that too.
Lucia: 但是一般可能做两个吧
Lucia: But typically, we might make two of them.
Shure: 6点半必须出门
Shure: You need to leave by 6:30.
Shure: 才一小时7分钟
Shure: It's only an hour and 7 minutes.
Shure: 还得去个安检什么的
Shure: You still need to go through security and all.
Alice:包包菜可爱
Alice: Wrapped cabbage is cute.
Alice:莲花白
Alice: Lotus cabbage.
Shure: 只能怪
Shure: You can only blame...
Katrina: 我靠这音乐姐真的想去
Katrina: Damn, this music really makes me want to go.
其他人：11点之后
Others: After 11 o'clock
其他人： 我还得从T2跑到T1去找我朋友去
Others: I still need to run from T2 to T1 to find my friend
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay
Shure: 他先到北京
Shure: He'll arrive in Beijing first
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Alice:莲花白这个名字明显比圆白菜好吃
Alice: The name "lotus white" obviously sounds tastier than "cabbage"
Shure: 我记得你飞到浦东还是虹桥
Shure: I remember you flew to Pudong or Hongqiao
Jake:就这个东西叫
Jake: This thing is called
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
其他人：虹桥虹桥
Others: Hongqiao, Hongqiao
Lucia: 叫啥
Lucia: What's it called?
Jake:就包菜
Jake: Just cabbage
Jake:很粗暴
Jake: Very rough
Lucia: 我还以为这个名字是叠词包包菜
Lucia: I thought the name was a repeated word "cabbage cabbage"
Jake:包包菜
Jake: Cabbage cabbage
Shure: 不止几百米吧
Shure: It's more than a few hundred meters, right?
Shure: T1和T2还挺远的
Shure: T1 and T2 are quite far apart
Alice:洋芋是土豆吗
Alice: Is "yam" a potato?
Alice:我们那不这么叫洋芋
Alice: We don't call it "yam" where I'm from
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Alice:地瓜红薯
Alice: Sweet potato
Lucia: 地瓜
Lucia: Sweet potato
Alice:洋芋
Alice: Yam
Lucia: 在我们那红薯就叫地瓜然后土豆叫洋芋
Lucia: Where I'm from, we call sweet potatoes "sweet potatoes" and potatoes "yam"
Tasha: 然后土豆叫洋芋
Tasha: And potatoes "yam"
Lucia: 都叫
Lucia: Both are called
Lucia: 再往西北走
Lucia: Further northwest
Alice:不叫洋芋
Alice: Not called "yam"
Jake:就就不叫土豆了
Jake: Then it's not called "potato"
Shure: 600
Lucia: 大家也知道土豆是什么
Lucia: Everyone knows what a potato is
Lucia: 哦不不怎么叫哦
Lucia: Oh no, not really called that
Alice:我们那不用洋芋这个名
Alice: We don't use the name "yam"
Alice:所以你说洋芋可能就有的
Alice: So if you say "yam" maybe some people
Alice:不就不知道啥
Alice: Won't know what it is
Alice:我们就是土豆
Alice: We just call it "potato"
Lucia: 那你们洋葱叫什么
Lucia: Then what do you call onions?
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion
Alice:阿年哈哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, Ah Nian, haha
Lucia: 就是啊啊呀
Lucia: Yeah, like, oh yeah
Lucia: 比如说甘肃和陕西是吧
Lucia: For example, Gansu and Shaanxi, right?
Tasha: 哦你也
Tasha: Oh, you too
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know
Lucia: 甘肃和新疆那边叫皮牙子
Lucia: In Gansu and Xinjiang, it's called Piyazi
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 皮牙子
Lucia: Piyazi
Jake:皮牙子
Jake: Piyazi
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 我也不知道为什么这么叫
Lucia: I don't know why they call it that
Lucia: 听着有点喜感
Lucia: It sounds kind of funny
Lucia: 但是总之就是那边会这么叫
Lucia: But anyway, they call it that over there
Tasha: 让我想起了皮燕子
Alice:还有什么啊
Alice: What else?
Jake:哈哈哈体验的是什么啊
Jake: Haha, what's the experience?
Tasha: 哈哈体验的是什么啊
Tasha: Haha, what's the experience?
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 皮燕哈哈哈
Tasha: Experience, hahaha
Lucia: 这个要给他解释吗
Lucia: Should we explain it to him?
Tasha: 嗯不要
Tasha: Um, no need
Jake:好对不起
Jake: Okay, sorry
Lucia: 你多上中文互联网冲一下
Lucia: You should browse the Chinese internet more
Tasha: 不不好意思
Tasha: No, sorry
Tasha: 我不是在故意在蹭饭的时候
Tasha: I didn't mean to talk about this while eating
Tasha: 吃饭的时候说这个
Tasha: While eating, I mean
Shure: 对啊你那算上燃油费才450470 才470
Shure: Yeah, including the fuel cost, it’s only 450-470, only 470
Lucia: 反正他也没听懂
Lucia: Anyway, he didn't understand
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Tasha: 是吗
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe
Tasha: 好
Jake:回头冲冲浪
Jake: I'll check it out later
Alice:杨老板昨天的照片太显年轻
Alice: Jake, you looked so young in yesterday's photo
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 哦你说GPT里的那个照片
Lucia: Oh, you mean the photo in GPT?
Tasha: GPT里
Tasha: In GPT?
Lucia: 它GPT账户头像
Lucia: His GPT account profile picture
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly
Jake:头像头像
Jake: Profile picture
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Alice:你喜欢这番茄酱
Alice: Do you like this ketchup?
Tasha: 这爱好不小众
Tasha: This hobby isn't that uncommon.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too.
Shure: 24号就是后天了
Shure: The 24th is the day after tomorrow.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Alice:来得及
Alice: There's still time.
Jake:你训起来了吗
Jake: Have you trained it?
Shure: 放弃了
Shure: Gave up.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:放弃了
Alice: Gave up?
Shure: 但是有购买记录了
Shure: But there's a purchase record.
Shure: 就是他他死无对证这个事情
Shure: So, he can't prove anything.
Shure: 因为他到期那个资源就给给我释放了
Shure: Because when it expired, the resource was released to me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对所以我说我训过
Shure: Yeah, so I said I trained it.
Shure: 他又不知道我训没训过是吧
Shure: He doesn't know if I trained it or not, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Exactly.
Alice:吃完了
Alice: Finished eating.
Alice:牛逼不嫌酸
Alice: Impressive, not too sour.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：周二机票会稍微降一点
Others: Ticket prices will drop a bit on Tuesday.
其他人：因为它会释放
Others: Because they'll release the extra seats.
其他人：那个就是空余的
Others: That's the extra ones.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我之前会去他们APP
Shure: I used to go to their app.
Shure: 上看就比如我去
Shure: Just to check, for example, if I went...
其他人：他没说什么时候
Others: He didn't say when.
Alice:下午几点录房间呢
Alice: What time are we recording in the afternoon?
Alice:现在收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's tidy up now.
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, right?
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:尽快吧
Jake: As soon as possible.
Alice:尽快
Alice: As soon as possible.
Jake:吃完吃完收拾收拾
Jake: Finish eating, then tidy up.
Jake:我开始扫
Jake: I'll start sweeping.
Jake:你们在外面待着
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Alice:那我去收拾一下下
Alice: Then I'll tidy up a bit.
Jake:或者在
Jake: Or...
Lucia: 还要再扫一遍
Lucia: Do we need to sweep again?
Jake:不要扫
Jake: Don't sweep.
Jake:扫一遍你们装饰之后的就长不一样了
Jake: After you decorate, it won't look the same if you sweep.
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Alice:找不同
Alice: Find the differences.
Lucia: 有一些有一些
Lucia: There are some, there are some.
Lucia: 美容值掉下来了
Lucia: The beauty points dropped.
Lucia: 我再回去粘一下
Lucia: Let me stick it back on.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Jake:好嘞那我先扫你的
Jake: Okay, I'll sweep yours first.
Jake:先扫你的屋子哦
Jake: I'll sweep your room first.
Tasha: 扫啊就现在
Tasha: Sweep, now?
Lucia: 你说我粘好之后哦
Lucia: After I stick it on, right?
Tasha: 就是扫装饰完的是吗
Tasha: Sweep after decorating, right?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Alice:我的也快扫吧因为我那个胶
Alice: Can you sweep mine too? Because the glue...
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice:他老掉对对对
Alice: It keeps falling off, yeah.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Lucia:  我今天早上起来发现他又掉了
Lucia: I found it fell off again this morning.
Lucia: 那我以为不用了
Lucia: So I thought I didn't need it.
Lucia: 我就没粘
Lucia: So I didn't stick it.
Lucia: 我想在上面粘一下然后再粘
Lucia: I want to stick it on top and then stick it again.
Alice:我全都在粘
Alice: I'm sticking everything.
Jake:那我先扫二楼
Jake: Then I'll sweep the second floor first.
Jake:我先扫你的屋子
Jake: I'll sweep your room first.
Jake:然后你的屋子
Jake: Then your room.
Jake:二楼就
Jake: The second floor...
Jake:我在二楼的时候你们就在一楼待着
Jake: When I'm on the second floor, you stay on the first floor.
Jake:然后你可以在一楼再贴一贴
Jake: Then you can stick more things on the first floor.
Jake:我下来的时候你就上去
Jake: When I come down, you go up.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Jake:就这么回事
Jake: That's the plan.
Alice:在院子应该也行都一样
Alice: Should be fine in the yard too, it's all the same.
Jake:哼哼你倒一点
Jake: Hmm, you pour a bit.
Lucia: 你给我倒点
Lucia: Pour me some.
Lucia: 我给你拿点别的
Lucia: I'll get you something else.
Lucia: 哈哈应该还有别的吗
Lucia: Haha, is there anything else?
Jake:哦到位了
Jake: Oh, it's in place.
Jake:挺好走一遍流程
Jake: Great, let's run through the process.
Tasha: 走一遍流程
Tasha: Run through the process.
其他人：然后最早下去
Others: Then go down first.
Lucia: 我去看看还有啥喝的给你拿一点
Lucia: I'll go see if there's anything to drink and get you some.
Jake:哼哼找找
Jake: Hmm, go look for it.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Jake:喝水里面有可乐喝
Jake: There's Coke in the water.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 可乐好像也没了
Shure: I think the Coke is gone too.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈发生什么事了
Jake: Haha, what happened?
Lucia: 差点把这玉米油给打了
Lucia: I almost knocked over the corn oil.
Shure: 加一下保一下身份证
Shure: Add and protect your ID card.
Jake:哈哈我靠
Jake: Haha, oh my God.
Jake:哈哈哈谢谢谢
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Lucia: 我靠第一反应这是个饮料瓶
Lucia: My first reaction was that it was a drink bottle.
Lucia: 对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:谢应该挺好喝
Jake: Thank you, it should taste good.
Tasha: nothing
Tasha: Nothing.
Tasha: 楼上有
Tasha: There's some upstairs.
Lucia: 有威士忌喝吗
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我和你一起整
Lucia: I'll join you.
Jake:搅拌搅拌
Jake: Stir, stir.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:威士忌油
Jake: Whiskey oil.
Jake:搅拌搅拌
Jake: Stir, stir.
Lucia: 笑死我了楼上应该还有什么喝的
Lucia: It cracks me up, there should be more drinks upstairs.
Tasha: Coca Cola我不喝有点喝不下了
Tasha: Coca-Cola, I can't drink it anymore.
Lucia: 好的薇薇喝嘛
Lucia: Okay, Tasha, drink it.
Tasha: 饱了
Jake:饿扁了喝不下了
Jake: I'm so hungry, I can't drink it.
Lucia: 我们还有这个今天应该不用了吧
Lucia: We still have this, we probably won't need it today.
Jake:哎这个好
Jake: Hey, this is good.
Jake:这个可以喝呵呵
Jake: This one can be drunk, haha.
Lucia: 这应该也还有
Lucia: There should be more of this too.
Jake:这个可以喝
Jake: This one can be drunk.
Lucia: 其他的好像没啥了
Lucia: There doesn't seem to be much else.
Jake:好够了喝
Jake: Okay, that's enough to drink.
Jake:足够
Jake: That's enough.
Jake:足够喝一壶
Jake: Enough to drink a whole pot.
Lucia: 足够喝一壶
Lucia: Enough to drink a whole pot.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这个是不是也是昨天晚上没喝完的
Lucia: Is this also from last night, unfinished?
Lucia: 但不知道这个有没有同学
Lucia: But I don't know if this one has any classmates.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 为你写诗为你
Tasha: Writing poems for you, for you...